Tessa's in Coeur d'Alene Idaho hi Tessa
how are you hello thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up so I kind of have a
two-part question we okay so we're on
baby step number two and we have
actually stopped paying our credit cards
so they're in default now why but
because there were self-employed both of
us are I quit my business and my so we
just did not income issue for sure and
so are you working new I am NOT I'm
currently trying to find a job I have
two little girls okay what was the last
job you had I own my own boutique from
home
what was the last job you had before
that that made money that they paid you
to do it was I worked at a gym and you
made what day care in the day minimum
wage what's around here's like $8.00 an
hour gotcha okay did your husband making
it his job his business um he is
currently making right around 45 a year
I'll tell you how much credit card add
have you got so we have three credit
cards two of them are maxed out at 6000
the third is maxed out at 12,000 but the
credit card company just sent us a thing
in the mail offering to settle with us
you don't have any money
I know so the thing is is we have my
husband's a car guys and so we have a
ton of cars and so we've been selling
those we have our thousand-dollar
emergency fund and we just sold a car
for 4,500 and you got an offer on one of
the six thousands for how much 25 take
it okay you got it in writing
you got it in writing do not give them
electronic
that's to your checking account make
sure that the statement is very clear of
what you've got in writing and you keep
a copy of the cashier's check that you
mail to them in your mail to them
immediately how many other cars can he
sell to clean up this debt before his
income goes up well okay so we have just
sold another truck last weekend we have
another one that was that was for five
hundred we have another one that was
going tonight for five hundred the guys
supposed to come over tonight good he
did stupid yeah
like a month into listening to your two
months in the listened years and he
bought another car with some of our
savings that I he came to a conclusion
over that sell so that really colors a
new home after you sell the $500 car
tonight how many more cars are sitting
there we probably have like ten cars
good lord
he's a car guy no he's no he's not a car
guy this is oh this is like nuts this is
beyond I'm a car guy but the car got
means you like cars it doesn't mean your
family is in jeopardy because of your
car addiction yeah we got to start
selling these things like all of them go
but basic transportation immediately you
can't pay your bills
there's no discussion about this these
are all for sale today every one of them
the last two that don't sell you get to
keep and both of you got to work to get
your incomes up to get this done and cut
up those stupid credit cards